a random variable can take different
numerical values depending on the
outcome of the experiment some outcomes
are more likely than others and
similarly some of the possible numerical
values of a random variable will be more
likely than others we restrict ourselves
to discrete random variables and we will
describe these relative likelihoods in
terms of the so called probability mass
function or PMF for short which gives
the probability of the different
possible numerical values the PMF is
also sometimes called the probability
law or the probability distribution of a
discrete random variable let me
illustrate the idea in terms of a simple
example we have a probabilistic
experiment with four possible outcomes
we also have a probability law on the
sample space and to keep things simple
we assume that all four outcomes in our
sample space are equally likely we then
introduce a random variable that
Associates a number with each possible
outcome as shown in this diagram the
random variable capital X can take one
of three possible values namely 3 4 or 5
let us focus on one of those numbers
let's say the number 5 so let us focus
on little X being equal to 5 we can
think of the event that capital X is
equal to 5 which event is this this is
the event that the outcome of the
experiment led to the random variable
taking a value of 5 so it is this
particular event which consists of two
elements namely a and B more formally
the event that we're talking about is
the set of all outcomes for which the
value the numerical value of run of a
random variable which is a function of
the outcome that numerical value happens
to be equal to 5 and in this example it
is a set consisting of 2 elements it's a
set of the sample space so it is an
event and it has a probability and that
probability we will be denoting with
this notation and in our case this
probability is equal to one-half because
we have two outcomes each one has
probability 1/4 the probability of this
event is equal to 1/2 more generally we
will be using this notation to denote
the probability of the event that the
random variable capital X takes on a
particular value little X this is just a
piece of notation not a new concept we
are dealing with the probability and we
indicated using this particular notation
more formally the probability that we're
dealing with is the probability the
total probability of all outcomes for
which the numerical value of our random
variable is this particular number
little X a few things to notice we use a
subscript capital X to indicate which
random variable we are talking about
this will be useful if we have several
random variables involved for example if
we have another random variable on the
same sample space Capital y then it
would have its own probability mass
function which would be denoted with
this particular notation here the
argument of the PMF which is little X
ranges over the possible values of the
random variable capital X so in this
sense here we're really dealing with a
function a function that we could denote
just by P with a subscript X this is the
function as opposed to the specific
values of this function and we can
produce plots of this function in this
particular example that we're dealing
with the interesting values of X
three four and five and The Associated
probabilities are the value of five is
obtained with probability one-half the
value of four this is the event that the
outcome was C which has probability 1/4
and the value of three is also obtained
with probability 1/4 because the value
of 3 is obtained when the outcome is d
and that outcome has probability 1/4 so
the probability mass function is a
function of an argument little X and for
any little X it specifies the
probability that our random variable
takes on this particular value a few
more things to notice the probability
mass function is always non-negative
since we're talking about probabilities
and probabilities are always
non-negative in addition since the total
probability of all outcomes is equal to
1 the probabilities of the different
possible values of the random variable
should also add to 1 so when you add
over all possible values of little X the
sum of the Associated probabilities
should be equal to 1 in terms of our
picture the events that X is equal to 3
which is this subset of the sample space
the event that X is equal to 4 which is
this subset of the sample space and the
event that X is equal to 5 which is the
subset of the sample space these three
events the red green and blue they are
disjoint and together they cover the
entire sample space so their
probabilities should add to 1 and the
probabilities of these event are the
probabilities of the different values of
the random variable capital X so the
probabilities of these different values
should also add to 1 let us now go
through a simple example to illustrate
the general method for calculating the
PMF of a discrete random variable
we will revisit our familiar example
involving two roles of a tetrahedral die
and let X be the result of the first
role y be the result of the second role
and notice that we are using uppercase
letters and this is because x and y are
random variables in order to do any
probability calculations we also need a
probability law so to keep things simple
let us assume that every possible
outcome there 16 of them has the same
probability which is therefore 1 over 16
for each one of the outcomes we will
concentrate on a particular random
variable defined to be the sum of the
random variables x and y so if x and y
both happen to be 1 then Z will take the
value of 2 if X is 2 and Y is 1 a random
variable will take a value of 3 and
similarly if we have this outcome in
those outcomes here the random variable
takes the value of 4 and we can continue
this way by marking for each particular
outcome the corresponding value of the
random variable of interest what we want
to do now is to calculate the PMF of
this random variable what does it mean
to calculate the PMF we need to find
this value for all choices of little Z
that is for all possible values in the
range of our random variable the way
we're going to do it is to consider each
possible value of little Z one at a time
and for any particular value find out
what are the outcomes the elements of
the sample space for which a random
variable takes on this specific value
and add the probabilities of those
outcomes so to illustrate this process
let us calculate the value of the PMF
for little Z equal to 2 this is by
definition the probability that our
random variable takes the value of 2 and
this is an event that can only happen
here it corresponds to only one element
of the sample space which
probability 1 over 16 we can continue
the same way for other values of little
Z so for example the value of PMF at
little Z equal to 3 this is the
probability that our random variable
takes the value of 3 this is an event
that can happen in two ways it
corresponds to two outcomes and so it
has probability 2 over 16 continually
continuing similarly the probability
that our random variable takes the value
of 4 is equal to 3 over 16 and we can
continue this way and calculate the
remaining entries of our PMF after you
are done you end up with a table or
rather a graph a plot that has this form
and these are the values of the
different probabilities that we have
computed and you can continue with the
other values it's a reasonable guess
that this would going to be 4 over 16
this is going to be 3 over 16 2 over 16
and 1 over 16 so we have completely
determined the PMF for for random
variable we have given the form of the
answers and it's always convenient to
also provide a plot with the answers
that we have